[MUSIC]
The technology enablers are now there.
And we're going to be
making that transition,
just as we are into self-driving cars,
into things like digital
currency transactions without
hardly even noticing it.
For example, when you buy that
cup of coffee at Starbucks and
you pay on your mobile phone.
It could be that the application program
interface in your phone last week flipped
from using your bank account to a payment
system based on digital currencies.
And you might have gotten a brief
notice with five pages of fine print
saying I agree at the end.
And as long as you hit that button,
you just made that transition
without noticing it.
I think it could be,
at the consumer level, as quick as that.
That's not to say that it's simple.
Hundreds of billions of dollars of
technology, software and hardware,
need to be built around this,
particularly software.
And a lot of legal work, and
a lot of regulatory work.
And the central banks have to go along
with it before it'll be allowed.
Because it's a concern,
it's part of the money supply.
And central banks will be responsible for
monitoring that.
And there are some countries that
are thinking about it, China, Sweden.
Those are two countries that are currently
contemplating introducing digital
currencies at the national level, through
the central banks of those countries.
So change is coming, and
I'm very interested in studying
the implications of that change.
[MUSIC]